welcome to the world of warcraft
survival guide for patch 7.2 the tomb of
Sargeras in this video will bring you up
to speed on all the changes and new
features coming in 72 up first we're
taking the fight to the Burning Legion
on the broken Shore the campaign begins
with khadgar in dollar on who sends you
on a mission to strike at the heart of
the legions base of operations after a
short scenario you'll have established a
base on the broken Shore and unlocked a
ton of new content including new world
quests rare monsters and a region-wide
cross faction effort to help the armies
of Legion fall keep hold of the broken
Shore in the process you'll discover a
quest that sends you in search of a
secret Legion communication which will
eventually leave to upgrading your
artifact with several new traits and a
new rank in many of your current traits
you'll also be given a highly
challenging single-player mission that
will test your abilities and ultimately
unlock a new artifact appearance while
we're establishing a foothold on the
broken Shore the Burning Legion has
already begun all-out assault on the
other zones in the broken Isles to push
them back you'll need to complete a
series of world quests in a given zone
followed by a daring mission to
infiltrate and take down the Legion
command ship Legion assaults can reward
gear reputation and even experience for
players below level 110
patch 72 will also allow you to complete
part 2 of the Legion Pathfinder
achievement and soar into the skies
above the broken Isles to do so you'll
need to explore the broken Shore fend
off the Legion assaults and earn revered
with the new armies of Legion fall
faction once you've earned both Legion
Pathfinder achievements flying in the
broken Isles will be unlocked for all
characters on your account including
your lower level alts 72 introduces PvP
brawls which bring exciting new twist to
some classic favorites in arathi
Blizzard winter has come to a ratty
basin with frozen lakes blankets of snow
and low visibility in gravity laps I of
the storm is experiencing some let's say
instability adding an extra layer of
mayhem and these are only a couple of
examples there will be a different pvp
brawl every other week and we'll be
adding more into the rotation as time
goes on 72 has a brand-new five player
dungeon available at all difficulty
levels the Cathedral of eternal night
you will ascend the tower above the tomb
of Sargeras alongside maiev and Illidan
in order to unleash the power of the
aegis of Agrabah one of the pillars of
creation and strike a decisive blow
against the Legion
on top of that we've made several
updates and tweaks to the rest of
legions five player dungeons the Ark way
and the court of stars can now be
completed on heroic difficulty and have
been added to the dungeon finder we've
added new affixes to mythic key stones
and brought upper and lower kara's on
into the mix and if you're not quite
ready to take on those challenges don't
worry we've increased the item level of
the rewards from all dungeons as well as
what you can earn from world quests and
emissary bags to help you tackle the new
72 content these are some of the biggest
things coming in patch 72 but there's a
lot more including a pet battle dungeon
new order hall followers and
improvements increases to artifact
knowledge and a new transmog sets
feature just to name a few as the Legion
fall campaign continues you'll also be
able to earn a class specific mount and
eventually take the fight directly to
the legions home base in the tomb of
Sargeras raid you can read more on our
website at world of warcraft com thanks
for watching and we'll see you on the
broken shore